[Applause]
we
are not going to allow this to become
the new normal
we are not prepared to allow our schools
to continue as killing fields
we
are not prepared to allow the gun lobby
and the gun industry to continue to run
this town and this place
we are never
ever
going to give up
until we make our schools we make our
shopping malls we make the streets of
this country a safe place to live and
work we are never ever giving up until
we win this fight
and this is a choice
this is not inevitable this is not
unchangeable we are the only country
in the world
in which our kids go to school wondering
whether they will survive the day
right
my
my fourth
fourth grader yesterday had to have
conversations all day at school with his
classmates that no child
that no ten-year-old should have to have
and he is forced to have those
conversations
with his friends about where they will
hide
about where they will run
because of decisions that are made in
this place
and we're going to change those
decisions